okay here we go I had a sneak into a
quick snack war zone rated 124 player
1765 average rating here we go
teaser for 5 - here we go get that thing
out of here
stay focused double those points and
let's roll how we gonna roll oh man what
a start that's ok now to do it the long
tournament home cookin pre move what's
going on L else we're here
water and a peanut butter nature Valley
granola bar 20 seconds I needed this
let's go here let's go boom what a start
oh look at scorpion the assassin
everybody should fear the assassin
fantasy you can do it you can do it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
take care
pawn push if the Queen's out whoa whoa
my trouble whoo I might be in trouble no
that's really to me oh I gotta do this
this is so ugly
oh no no no say it isn't so please say
it isn't so why didn't they take my
knight I'm gonna go here I want to hang
on to my knight now I'm afraid to not
hang on to my knight
let's go for cover skis right around the
corner where are they gotta hang on to
that oh man oh man right here there's
gonna be Queen check though pawn push I
get the bishop I'm gonna try it
hopefully it works I want to get that
bishop give me that Bishop I want to
push the Queen around Forks
okay I can block with the Queen check
right here everything is nice and cozy
cozy positions right here defend defend
and get developed finally a little scary
over here still scary town no time
though no time no time no time they
resigned back to tournament 16 scorpion
69 has 16 points okay I have five
handful of sixes alright let's go
Game three early Game two there was
nothing going on came one okay trying
trying is here okay what do we should
have just taken ah man I should have
just taken so I could enter a fishing
land I could become a fisherman right
there okay pin that night and then get
to the e5 square u 5 square I want to
attack that pinned piece now attack all
right let's do this chop chop chop chop
grab this and then get my other night
here okay
I'm having a funny feeling about this
I'm having a funny feeling I know what's
up I know what's up I know the tricks
these guys play much stronger those
rating what's going on here check let's
do it even though I'm dropping upon can
I get this guy did I get him I got him
uh-oh Oh pigs pigs pigs watch out for
the pigs pigs let's hang out in a pig
hit a rug hit a rook be very scared be
very scared
check are they scared are they scared is
the big question here
oh I want to avoid that I want to get a
flight square also let's do this pawn
push pawn push let's do that
it's a little scary I'm gonna take here
though I'll trade now a little bit more
I think let's come over here and then
here I don't have a six point oh I don't
have any time I don't have any time uh
no time five point seven seconds I'm
dropping that pun I gotta come back oh I
got that rook gonna let me go oh how
much time I can't breathe I can't move
they're down oh man I'm sorry if I'm
being loud I can't I can't I don't know
what to say oh I just can't do anything
but hold my breath if that if the if it
gets too tense my um my defense right
there is don't just hold your breath
it'll be okay
just hold your breath everything will be
okay it's a very good strategy if you're
in a pickle hold your breath and count
to however high you need to count you
just need to hold your breath apparently
oe5 kicked this night away I should have
won that but I want it now five right
around the corner f5 be scared be scared
I think that was a tricky player
somebody was being tricky they're like
hey I'm gonna create a sneaky account
and be better than my rating
I know those traits I know those sneak
attacks uh Queens off oh I was ready to
throw an in-betweener but I was in check
okay here's the plan
get in g4 oh I shouldn't have done that
let's do this
broke up and over time is even that's a
wonderful sight let me tell you let me
do this now the classic rook up and over
rook up and then over forget about g4
forget about it forget about it the king
actually with this I'm saying let's play
on the Queen side right now let's go
night you can't go too far can you he's
going down he's definitely going I want
to avoid the rook exchange no there's
gonna be a c4 move why did I do that
that was silly
how am I to do that okay I have to go
into defensive mode what's the clock
what's the clock saying the clock once
again my best friend in these positions
here when there's nothing to do or I'm
down on time when I'm down on pieces you
know what I meant King position anything
anything this this game is not gonna
finish just primo primo primo primo
primo come on don't what's going on here
ah they're down on time okay back to
tournament 42 Oh
42:27 let's go accept that let's go I
need to go fishing and fishing fast I
need to get quick hills really really
quick kills where are they
are they close to happening you know you
want a Castle kingside oh they're not
castling in that direction okay I have
before if they're gonna go Queen side b4
opens up the befall at least at least
the B file okay
well they're gonna go Queen side get out
of there bishop don't you dare get out
of there
dark square weaknesses dark square
weaknesses dark square weaknesses Oh
let's come back here oh my Knights dead
oh don't try and get that I should grab
the night I got the knight now I want
the c3 pawn really really soon right
here Oh
over here to defend and that Bishop was
gonna kill me if I didn't play that I
almost missed that I don't want to deal
with that six my bishop wants to be here
and then here and then my bishop wants
to be here right here but not so fast
there okay it could go fast there now if
it came over to this file there would
have been a problem I get this I'm
crashing through the Queen is active the
pig looking for pigs pigs pigs two rooks
two pigs they resigned back to
tournament that was kind of quick forty
two thirty four thirty thirty twenty
nine twenty minutes left a lot of time
here
let's roll here and time they're not
firing this one up yes they are
efore less than twenty minutes now a non
mover there wouldn't be this guys having
a good tournament okay he has 19 points
he's doing well let's go gambit land oh
you know you want to take that pawn I
didn't take that pun
alright I'm setting things up i think am
i being clever hmm let's do this
and okay connect these guys and I'm
gonna go Queen side I'm gonna get my
Queen out to an active square and I
didn't I want to do that right now
before there's a nasty piling up on my
night right there wasn't a pin it's a
castle something here I'm gonna play
this if the Queen goes there or maybe
take on b7 that's why the play that's
why the Queen played there let's pin the
night maybe night here here okay
pins everywhere pin here pin here night
here hit the bishop hit the clean it the
knight hit the pond everything is hit
the whole family is being hit right now
two pins two pins I have the Queen the
whole family was hit right there and now
I think after the smoke clears
everything is okay for team what for
team whoo let's do this let's trade a
little bit just a little bit
okay let's support everything there
would have been a fork if there would
Bend bishop trade first let's play here
giving Czech leading to mate hopefully
get out of there bishop oh free bishop
discoveries is real soon dark square
weaknesses I want to get at them where
the dark square weakness is meeting one
two right here let's give a check where
the mates check ok they they dread up
there down on time
56 42 42 42 41 41 okay I think cap ended
up losing a game somebody stopped him in
his tracks we got Mike 9 8 - okay this
is entering a French isn't it let's take
here I must mouse slip there maybe I
should have tried c4 can I build my
center here let's get this in building
my center let me support that night
gotta watch out for this pawn right here
and I don't know if that's really doing
well to support it light square
weaknesses though seems really active
right here pressure against this point
maybe the knight is pinned and I should
play here okay they're out of the pin I
want to capture like this still want to
capture like this and I want to know I
can't even stop that let's let's do this
right here and then get my king up it's
a little bit scary to do something like
that I guess we're gonna be trading
Queens do I have anything better to
focus on my King position right now
support that power before it's too late
and I should consider maybe that light
squares light squares where are they
what's the time situation I'm gonna try
this I have this as a past pond but it's
still really really tough I would have
gotten uh I would have been in a fork if
I played my knight here right away
because of b4 what's the okay my knight
has a good position now can I get that
pawn with check I think I'm getting it
whit's check
oh okay wait this is a past pond over
here
my dodging checks by going here I think
I'm getting this the King can't track it
down I'm guarding the Queen's Square
already give check here and then oh okay
I have it check and then give a check
here they're down the time back to
tournament I mean I thought I was in
10th I'm in fifth 55 56 look at this a
bunch of 55 and 56 is neck-and-neck
right here a lot of time left were not
even at the halfway point okay stay calm
here don't hold your breath whatever you
do oh this guy has such a lead on time
here that's how that's how it works
though isn't it that's the risk you take
isn't it okay let's defend this pawn and
launch the Jeep on it's being lodged
real soon
it wants to be launched and okay well
they're over in this direction let's
play here Bishop f3 pawn push in the
center there might be a knight pivot
let's open this up what's going on here
hit this and then I'm gonna do that I
don't want the file to open up right
against my queen I'm on the bishop I'm
on this pond and I'm gonna take here and
then Center up my night right here forks
forks forks I just barely saw that how
much time pigs pigs pigs pigs I'm I'm
threatening a mane oh I'm in a fork come
on can we trade I don't have any time
I'm losing pawns
oh man Man Man Man Man Man Man ah man I
don't have anything I can't win this can
I I want this pawn
and I'm anytime I'm dead I'm so dead
man I don't have anything can I get the
rook ah I have to resign button that was
sneaky oh man I fell back 53 uh man
stopped right in my tracks don't you
dare give up now don't you dare give up
ah man they hit me back with the fork
right there I got fork you could do it
you could do it you could do it don't
you dare have quitting you don't you
dare say no to quitting forks say yes to
Ford's though here we go Oh get out of
there
I want that night and I need to get out
of pins I'm going down swinging if I'm
going down tell you what I'm going down
swinging
check problems
check out the problems hit the pink
pieces don't don't take the pink pieces
attack the pink pieces the queen is in
rough shape right now she's in rough
shape
hang on don't take the pinch piece take
my own advice don't you dare take that
right away I'm gonna do this I think it
works tricky tricky tricky looking for
the tricks oh man I'm not gonna get any
quick one right here
checks grab this pawn it seems right
let's do it
it's actually it also seems unnecessary
just take the [ __ ] up whoa okay let's
come over here with the rook that'd be
nice
hit the King
it should have been a lot easier I must
have missed seven things already time is
seven things they have no time time
burners anything anything anything
anything anything anything just we'll
just move the game is not gonna end 69
113 110 uh way back in the field right
here King King Kai 10 let's go for this
11 minutes and change oh that last
killed me it killed me I tell you
fishing I have to go fishing right here
d4 I need my bishop right there my
knight I don't have six I'm come on you
know you want to fall right into it you
know you want to fall right into it in
Castle oh man they're sniffing it out
already they're sniffing it out already
okay I get this pond though now it's
gonna be taken back I got to play Bishop
here Oh or not that's a free piece now
Forks right around the corner Castle
rook to d1 no don't you dare don't you
dare dark swear weaknesses though okay
okay okay okay
pawn push and then Queen to e4 is the
big bad plan are they gonna castle they
are gonna Castle Queen to e4 coming up
right away me in that well it's not a
mate in one threat I kicked that night
away I can't do that and I can't do that
either the bishop was just gonna block
if I gave a check I get that night out
of there the knight is running out of
squares and the knight is dead now I
could play here because of Forks but no
it's not going there okay tricky stuff
here or is it let's give a check and
then take here and then take here with
check main and to actually that's how it
would work out this is check and that
would have been
check where is the where the checkmates
that's checkmate okay that was kind of
quick 87 133 130 129 101 oh I still have
a lot of games to get in somehow let's
go here can I get top three
can I get can I break three digits let
me work on that first way leg is having
a fantastic tournament up there 133
let's go this let's go this everybody's
sniffing it out queenside castle or
Kings side man everybody isn't they
already know I know what the scoop is
yeah did you play that guy yeah keeps
trying that fishing pole are you playing
that guy who keeps playing that fishing
pole line yeah I can hear it already
that's the talk that's going around yeah
he keeps going for that darn fishing
pole what do you do about that here we
go hit this night I've been trying to
get this B 5 move in and finally it's
here the long-awaited B 5 move and now
everything is hit pieces r1 the king is
running for the hills
and I'm gonna get Castle before I drop
this guy and in response to g4 I'll play
h4 just so there's nothing fancy going
on I'll grab that f2 pun no and I was
gonna say in response the Queen takes
pawn there but slightly tweaked but same
story isn't it ok give check on the dark
my bishop wants to be in light and it
can't go to light because the Queen is
guarding it so let's make some
adjustment let's give a check here and
let's throw a pig on the second because
that's what you should be doing with
your pigs and with the bishop guard the
back rank as well and kill the Queen
soon I can grab that pot and then give a
check let's do that
good enough actually there's probably a
mate anyhow no time to do it 153 150 149
I'm about 50 points off from even top
three land
in minutes and change f4 Knight f3 oh
stuff is falling isn't it let's do this
kick that night away where's he gonna
run to is he scared
get out of there Knight I want to do
that before I push here otherwise
there's a knight III move I want to kick
that night away again I think let's do
this Queen takes have a 4-course key
although there is a queen check in
response to it so yeah let's not do that
just yet I really want to get this in
can you tell it's not happening though
okay was worth a shot let's go here push
the night away grab the pond that'll be
nice okay there's Queen takes pawn with
check or there's that okay move your
pieces grab this pond - or this pun
maybe back up the bishop hit the Queen
grab on f7 or play here actually I
should have played here I'm not even
sure what that move was doing okay mate
in one threat this has to be right has
to be right this is leading to main
maintenance move the Queen has to block
they resigned back to tournament 127 173
171 forty-nine six minutes and change
can I somehow weasel my way back I'm
looking to weasel my way back there's
maybe just three more games three four
five at the most five at the most the
most get out of there Bishop you go back
you get trapped okay no I'm gonna go for
what go for it all here go for the gusto
let's go oh right let's do this open up
that diagonal and I want to break this
structure down I think but I probably
want to get queenside castle and first
let's do that it's very scary my king
and queen are on the same file you
cannot be excited about that
can you let's let's do it it's ready to
get blown open here trying to blow it
open right here you know you want to
take that pawn you know it you know you
want to take that pun yes they did want
to take that pun
now what do we do oh this is this is
crumbling pins everywhere
pin City pin City grab a pawn with check
looking for mate
soon real soon where's the mate I don't
want the Queens to come off I didn't
want that to happen where is the mate
let's do this and then let's try that
again
why is it happening like this I have to
defend this square
I never so it's sort of something so
much better why did I ever do a move
like that that was so stupid
ah fifteen seconds these are taking
forever
get out of there Bishop ah man I had me
that I just I know I had me somewhere I
mean just I didn't even capture the
bishop I'm thinking that I captured the
bishop I better win this one at least
let's take this I'm on it right here I'm
just dropping stuff now do you realize
it's throwing pre moves is this mate
is this me just check just come back Oh
what an awful one don't ever look at
that one getting I mean top ten wow I
was talking about oh no this guy right
here the big bad wolf wolf man this guy
usually has me running for the hills
man I have I have a bad feeling against
wolf man here the only games I've won
were ones where it was just the clock on
my side okay let's try this the wolf man
is ready to give me just another beating
and a half I could feel it I'm feeling
it already I know it's happening any
moment the wolf man is having no more of
my silly little antics I'm gonna take
that bishop I want to get to see five
can we make that happen please this
Knight needs to get kicked around to get
out of there
let's come over here it's it's fun uncie
five isn't it not anymore
what about B five what about F 4 and E
six mm maybe not because the night is
gonna be licking his chops on the e4
square Queens are coming out very soon I
could feel it in now and now you don't
want to drop pawns you don't want to
move into a pen I was ready to play King
F - don't do that
now you could do it since the rook left
the F file and you can't go any further
can you King you cut off you are cut off
what a sad day take the pawn you know
you want to take that pawn yes it's a
fork of ruski tricky Knights variation
come on King you could defend I think I
have wolf man on the ropes wolf man stop
it wolf man I want to get active with my
rook activity activity for the rook grab
this guy come over here time situation
is looking pretty gonna have this pawn
he's free he should be free he's he's
down he resigned wolf man - 32091 81 168
I have 167 can I get a quick win where
the quick wins the boost I needed 187
who's in third
can I get second somehow 222 haha a very
timely boost very very timely boost
right there I needed a boost right there
and I got it everybody needs a quick
resigner every now and then two minutes
and change this might be the last game
might be let's go let's roll here going
right after the King for kuru skis on f7
Forks watch out for meeee
are they gonna resign that would be
wonderful please just resign ah they
didn't resign just take this Knight no I
don't want the night to get active or
the rook defiled open up the G file but
now I'm gonna take him cuz he's a free
guy he's a free night
okay pin a knight get rid of them
throw a pig on the seventh really soon
pigs one pig they're looking for another
shortly thereafter
get out of there Bishop oh how many my
lips are they gonna take the bait take
them I meant to play a four let's just
trade Queens please just trade Queens a
little bit just stay connected get over
here defend grab that pond cuz he's free
grab free stuff ah I'm not grabbing free
stuff and I should know dropping stuff I
want oc7 is where I want to be I also
want to grab the Queen come on you know
you wanna resign yes back to term in 207
oh there's only 45 seconds I need to get
a quick win 43 42 41 I need to get a
quick win where's the quick win okay
okay this could work out decent maybe
Castle you know you want a castle you
know you want to fall for the fishing
fishing land right around the corner is
it gonna happen please just take the
night let me have the possibility of
doing something good still take him he's
free he's got to be free at this point
he's got to be even more free now for
the no man what can you do man man get
the wind right out of my sails took the
wind right out of my sails games off 250
229 207 207 oh they a tie for third why
did they get that tie break what's the
tiebreak what do they look into how many
games you have in you know man somebody
got right up there cat
was top I had a hand their memory me way
leg he was up there at one point
133 when he had 133 he was in first
oh man